today on the Matt Walsh show there's
been a slew of assaults against white
people recently now the media doesn't
care about this at all isn't paying any
attention to it
but more importantly the crimes are not
being charged as hate crimes they're not
being considered hate crimes why is that
why shouldn't they be hate crimes we'll
talk about that today also five
headlines including NASCAR coming out
fully in support of the black driver who
says that someone left a noose in his
garage now there there are several
strange aspects to this story is it a
hoax we'll talk about that today
and finally in today's cancellation I am
canceling Karen not Karen's not a woman
named Karen but the Karen mean the Karen
thing I'm gonna cancel today and I'll
explain why all of that coming up and we
start with this first of all in fact I
did get this big big big moment
I did get my first presidential retweet
last night always an exciting moment
kind of a coming of age for conservative
pundits when they get the the Trump
retweet and the post of mine on Twitter
that Trump retweeted was this video
which we discussed yesterday on the show
and let me play it for you again here
[Music]
that right there as we talked about
yesterday is a white Macy's employee
being brutally assaulted by a black man
in the middle of the store which and
this is this happened a few days ago the
video shows the assailant his name's
Damir Palmer punching a man in the head
as you saw as he as you crawls on the
ground begging for Palmer to stop if
you're listening to us on iTunes you
don't have the video that's that's what
you see there the assailants brother who
filmed the crime and posted it proudly
to social media claims that the victim
used the n-word prior to this assault
taking place now even if that was true
that wouldn't remotely justify felony
assault but it isn't true
Macy's investigated they confirmed the
attack was unprovoked
also the n-word claim is just absurd on
its face a Macy's employee is not gonna
casually refer to his black customers as
as a racial slur okay if he was in the
habit of doing that he would have been
fired a long time ago Macy's is not
gonna fall on the sword to defend an
employee who uses racial slurs that's
just not something corporations are
gonna do now what actually happened from
the looks of it is that Palmer's the
Palmer brothers selected a victim based
on his race beat him mercilessly and
then slandered him they damaged him
physically and then tried to ruin his
life
for good measure if the hate crime
designation has any meaning this should
fit the bill yet to this point no hate
crime charges have been filed in fact no
charges of any kind have been filed as I
say this right now there's been that the
guy who carried out the assault has not
been arrested even though it's on video
we have it right there and they know his
name somehow hasn't been arrested no
charge at all as at all had been filed
so far because of that it should be
noted that a man who assaulted a Macy's
employee last year was charged with a
hate crime a somewhat similar situation
just in the fact that was a Macy's
employee being insult assaulted in the
store and and that person was charged
with a hate crime but in that case it's
because he used anti-gay slurs during
the attack it's not clear to me that the
customer or the employee was actually
gay I'm not sure if he was or not all it
says in the news reports is that the
person carrying out the assault used
anti-gay slurs the prosecutor in the
case said that the attacker quote
subjected the victim to offensive
physical contact and this was done quote
because of his perception of the victim
sexual orientation well was this latest
Macy's assault not offensive physical
contact and was it not due to the
attackers perception of the victims race
how is one a hate crime and this isn't
now this unfortunately is not an
isolated incident recently there's
a slew of horrific physical attacks
against white people last week a group
of black men attacked a white man in a
gas station parking lot in Texas and
this is all everything I'm talking about
here these are all on video they punched
him they knocked him to the ground they
stomped on his head when he was lying
there now I'm not gonna play all these
videos for you because they're pretty
violent and they're disturbing and I'm
not gonna force you to watch them if you
don't want to but you can go to my
Twitter feed and you can you can find
them I've linked all of them there and I
would recommend if you think you can
stomach it just go you it's one of those
things you have to sort of see for
yourself to understand the severity of
the situation in New York a black man
pushed a 92 year old white woman to the
ground she bashed her head against a
fire hydrant as she felt she's 92 years
old no hate crime charges have been
filed
she was going along on her Walker down
the street this guy walks by just pushes
her it walks away in another attack
against the elderly Jaden T Hayden of
Michigan maybe he saw this video he was
repeatedly beating a 75 year old nursing
home patient in the head as he lay
helpless on his bed now the interesting
thing is that Hayden has YouTube videos
where he claims that among other things
quote the black race is supposed to rule
the earth no hate crime charges have
been filed so far in this case but try
to imagine the same outcome if a white
man with similar professed views about
the white race let's say a white man who
had YouTube video saying that the white
race is supposed to rule the earth and
then in and then if that man were to go
and film himself brutalizing an elderly
black man how quickly do you think hate
crime charges would be filed in that
case like within 10 seconds that maybe
at the speed of light they would be they
would come out there are more examples
and in fact we'll get to those those
other examples in just a second but
before we do this show today is brought
to you by zero you know it's very
frustrating when there's you know
there's a lot of people there's that one
spot in your house that has better Wi-Fi
than the rest of
your house maybe you have that and a lot
of times it's it's the one spot where
you want to hang out and be and it
doesn't get the Wi-Fi sick now in my
house it's living living out in the
wilderness in the middle of nowhere at
the top of a mountain which isn't quite
exactly where I live but still
relatively relatively out out in the
woods pretty much the whole house is
that situation and that's why Eero is
Wi-Fi that your home deserves a blankets
your whole home with fast reliable Wi-Fi
not just inside but also outside too so
you can go out hang out on the porch
it's nice out here Oh extends your
coverage so you can enjoy the nicer
weather and get work done from your deck
Eero eliminates poor coverage dead spots
and buffering you'll have a consistently
strong signal wherever you need it
eros steps up sets up in minutes it's
very easy to do I've done it myself you
can plug right into your modem or your
router box and and you can manage it
from a very simple app it's just it's
extremely simple to do and right now
I've gone through this I've set it up
and I'm enjoying not in this house go
this isn't where I live we're just
squatting here I don't know who lives
here but maybe I'll maybe I'll set up a
euro for them too but in my house we've
set it up in and now all of our Wi-Fi
problems are solved you can get yours
fixed as soon as tomorrow go to eurocom
slash Walsh enter code walls to check
out to get free next day shipping with
your order that's EE R o comm slash
Walsh code Walsh at checkout to get your
arrow delivered with free next day
shipping you must use this URL to
receive this offer it's eurocom slash
walsh code walsh all right so other
examples of these assaults we were
talking but during the riots in
Rochester a few weeks ago a white woman
was attacked by a group of black men she
was punched in the in the face
repeatedly beaten with a wooden board in
Ocean City where violence has been
rampant of late there have been several
examples of this but there's one video
where a guy is sitting on a park bench
and is knocked out knocked to the floor
again no hate crime charges and hate
crime charges aren't the only thing
missing here there has been little
public attention - or condemnation of
these attacks in fact I've been told
that it's race
to even talk about them if you go to my
Twitter feed and you see where I had
these videos posted whether it's the
Macy's one of the longer thread where I
post all of the the videos I just
mentioned you find lots of people either
outright defending felony assaults of
white people or insisting that I'm a
racist for calling attention to it and
there's no explanation provided they
don't explain why it's racist to point
out when a when a white person is
brutally assaulted it's assumed that we
all we all understand like it's a given
but well of course that's racist you
can't do that why can't you do it Val
you just can't it's just not something
you can do that's all just a few random
examples here are some responses
justifying the assault of the Macy's
employee which you saw just just a few
random responses on my page one person
says an eyewitness says the black man
asked the employee a question then
became angry when the Macy's salesperson
who was on his phone used the n-word
when he got back to his call thinking
had done so discreetly so no it's not a
hate crime it's a guy angered by racism
so there's a person saying that that
basically it's okay because he was angry
about a word that he heard now as I've
already said that word was not said
these guys made that story up it's very
clear that they made it up and the story
is absurd on its face but regardless
beat a man to a pulp because you heard a
words you don't like no someone else
says he is he's clearly saying I'm sorry
implying that he indeed SID said or did
something to result in getting Punk'd
like that making the white guy a victim
is far-fetched I know plenty of white
men like this that pop off at the mouth
and expect nothing bad to happen it's
far-fetched that video you just saw with
a white man on the ground being pummeled
it's far-fetched to say that he's a
victim someone else says firstly three
punches isn't brutally assaulted second
if it was a white person beating a black
person I'm sure you will believe the
black person must have done something to
deserve it and even go so far as to dig
up criminal past criminal records the
problem it's it's a problem no matter
what we do so it's not brutally
assaulting that wasn't a brutal aside
just a regular assault just a Reds a
regular it's just a standard standard
assault no problem there and then other
other stuff like that now once again the
guy did not say the end where the story
was fabricated but the idea that the
assailant is entitled to commit felony
assault
because of a bad word is floozy
and it's all besides the point the
attack was unprovoked as where most of
the attacks that I just listed yet no
hate crime charges have been filed now
let me say that I am not personally a
proponent of the hate crime designation
I don't like it I don't think the
prosecutors can look into a criminals
heart and accurately assess whether a
crime was motivated by hatred or not I
don't know how they can do that they
can't do it and even if they could I'm
not sure why a crime of hate should be
considered any more severe than a crime
of greed or jealousy or anger or boredom
or indifference is it really worse to
shoot a man for his race than for his
wallet haven't you treated him as less
than human
either way haven't you killed him either
way isn't he just as dead in both cases
isn't his family mourning him just the
same no matter what now the common
argument the common response to that is
that hate crimes have a special effect
on the community and that they terrorize
and intimidate people so that's why
there's a reason to respond
especially aggressively to them and it's
true that you know an actual hate crime
is gonna terrorize a community but then
criminals who kill people for money or
for their shoes or for the cash in the
register also terrorize communities and
intimidate communities set beset by such
crime are often crippled by fear if you
live in a community like that he's like
you don't you don't even wanna let your
kids leave the house so I don't see much
of a difference in that case either
people
crippled by fear and and and and
terrorized for different reasons but
they're still terrorised they're still
in fear and people are still dying
there is no reason to think that hatred
is the worst possible motivator for a
crime I would say that in fact that
indifference to human life is actually
the worst and it motivates the worst
kinds of crime mass shootings many mass
shooting school shootings serial killers
Psychopaths these are people who don't
care about human life enough to you know
they don't care about human life enough
to hate it like they're gonna kill you
and but they don't care about you enough
to hate you you just mean nothing to
them they're indifferent to you totally
empty inside killing just for the fun of
it just for the thrill now that seems to
me to be a reason to kill someone at
least as evil as hate but then again
killing someone if it's not in
self-defense or in defense of somebody
else is evil no matter what and I'm not
convinced that there can be a more or
less evil reason to do it the whole
conversation becomes absurd after a
while yet this is what our justice
system has done it's come up with a sort
of tier system ranking the reasons to
kill people or assault people from worst
to best this is a really bet this is a
you know a bad reason but not the worst
reason and this is this reason is a
little bit worse and this is the the
worst reason to do it it's ridiculous
and not only is that ranking system
subjective but the judgement of why
someone performed an act it's also
subjective so this is subjectivity on
top of subjectivity and that's why we
shouldn't have the hate crime label at
all in my opinion but if we're going to
go down this road
if we if we've gotten into the business
of doling out special punishments for
hate based crimes and if we have assumed
that prosecutors and judges have
mind-reading abilities then equal
justice under the law means prosecuting
crimes against white people with all the
same gusto as crimes against non white
people and that's not happening here
and that's an injustice all right let's
move on to your headlines number one as
mentioned yesterday on the show NASCAR
driver Bubba Wallace says that someone
hung a noose in his NASCAR garage
Wallace of course is black the story has
been reported everywhere
the huge deals been made of it it's been
reported as fact everywhere just
straight forwardly the media the
headline saying a noose was found in the
garage they're not saying allegedly
reportedly it was claimed that so on and
so forth none of that just news was
found yesterday at Talladega the other
drivers came together to push Wallace's
car to the start line in a show of
solidarity NASCAR itself has gone all in
supporting Wallace rallying around him
here's a video they put out today we
want to stand with our friend and we
want to sing with Bob and that's what
took place through last night this
morning and then as this idea came
together today and it started within the
driver as a menace the crew members
caught wind that we wanted to push about
this car down
and stand with him during the national
anthem the team's wanted to get involved
as well and you saw the supports pretty
amazing this garage area is going to
stand together stronger than ever
as that message continues to gets in you
know I Love You Man
we all do take care yourself out there
put us in a good spot
get yourself a deep breath get your mind
right oh shut these haters up as Bubba
Wallace guns it from the inside with
Joey Logano and Kevin Harvick I'm proud
to stand where I'm at sport is changing
[Music]
so Bubba Wallace is now famous and
renowned whereas before if you didn't
follow a NASCAR you probably hadn't
heard of him I hadn't heard of them I
haven't heard of any really any NASCAR
drivers I don't I don't follow it but
and he's being a hailed as a hero for
his bravery and standing up to racism
he's put out a statement several
statements now where he talks about how
he was he's not gonna be intimidated
he's not gonna back down he's gonna
fight racism and everything meanwhile
federal authorities are investigating
the incident but here's the weird thing
still to this point we have seen no
photo of this news now keep in mind the
noose was supposedly discovered by one
of Wallace's crew you know crew members
and in that person saw it and then went
old Wallace that's the story were given
but we know that the guy who found it
obviously would have taken a picture
that's the first thing you're gonna do
because for one thing you want to show
Wallace right so does he take out his
phone I'm gonna take a picture
it's what anybody would do
we haven't seen this picture that's kind
of strange isn't it
why haven't we seen it two days later
and still no picture
also these garages that NASCAR races are
under lock and key you know highly
restricted area very tight security
cameras everywhere right this isn't
something that a fan can just wander
into so it's not like some random racist
fan went in and did that it's not
possible so if it was done if this was
actually a hate crime if somebody put it
there as a racist attack against
publiced then it would have had to have
been you know a NASCAR employee or
someone who works you know and someone
is on someone officially involved
someone employed would have had to do
that somebody with access and this would
also be someone who would have known
that they would be immediately found out
because they would know about the
security would have had to go through
all that security just to get to that
area and so they would have known that
my question is what a what an employee
with access would they be so racist will
they be so overcome with racism that
they would sacrifice their job and their
livelihood and their freedom because
they're gonna go David go to jail for
this that they did it they're gonna
sacrifice everything just to hang a
noose
I mean even supposing that there's a
NASCAR employee with access who is
racist would he essentially commit
suicide for the sake of this stunt maybe
so
who knows people are crazy people do
crazy things but still there is the
other explanation and it happens that
this other explanation is what has
explained almost every new story we've
heard in recent years and that's that
the story is a hoax or at best
somebody misinterpreted what they saw
and now they're just running with it
because the thing is with with NASCAR
doing that and coming out and support
and they've got the drivers walking down
the track and everything they're all in
they they can't it would be a total
embarrassment to them if they were to
come out and say oh you know what
actually it was it was it was a hoax or
it was misinterpreted
not to mention NASCAR's gonna be accused
of racism no matter what even if there
is ear irrefutable evidence that this
was all a hoax or misunderstanding if
NASCAR Brooke were to come out now and
say that they're gonna be accused of
racism and they're not believing a black
man and all that kind of stuff so I
think very likely if this was a hoax
we're never gonna find out but also
we're never gonna see a picture of this
supposed news number two race hustler
and all-around scumbag Shaun King who's
you know by the way one of the worst
people currently living on planet Earth
is now inciting attacks on churches here
but here's what he said let me pull it
up few tweets he sent out he said yes I
think the statues of the white European
they claim as Jesus should also come
down they are a form of white supremacy
always have been in the Bible when the
family of Jesus wanted to hide and blend
in guess where they went
Egypt not Denmark tear them down and
then later he also says yes all murals
and stained glass windows of white Jesus
and his European mother and their white
friends should also come down they re
gross form of white supremacy created as
tools of oppression racist propaganda
they should all come down so this of
course is the next step
first the Confederate statue then
Columbus then founders other presidents
then on to religious statues that was
always the next step remember this is a
war on Western civilization that's the
objective here it's got nothing to do
with racism whatsoever
these are people who hate Western
civilization despite the fact that
Western civilization gave them freedom
liberty luxury unimaginable to almost
everyone else who has lived on earth
anywhere at any point in history despite
all that they hate Western civilization
and they're tearing down whatever
represents the foundations of our
civilization Christianity is the
foundation of the foundation it lies at
the very root of Western civilization of
course of course that's next there was
never any doubt about it and when they
start tearing down the Jesus statues
please don't be shocked that was always
going to happen number three
speaking of tearing down monuments
Democrat politicians of course are
actively and explicitly encouraging
these felonies here's the latest from
Andrew Cuomo the governor of New York
and a man who of course consigned
thousands of elderly people to their
deaths here's what he has to say about
the monuments president Trump mentioned
in an interview that he feels cities to
take further action to stop monuments
from being destroyed we saw that scene
at the White House with the Andrew
Jackson statue near the White House we
know for example Theodore Roosevelt
statue is coming down in New York City
do you agree with the president's
guidance that the cities should do more
to protect monuments
yeah I don't even know what the
president's guidance is Savannah frankly
cities are making decisions the Teddy
Roosevelt statue I think was most of us
that Teddy Roosevelt but the the other
parts of that of that statue and looking
people are making a statement about
equality about community to be against
racism against slavery I think those are
good statements and it depends you know
can you overdo it of course you can but
in New York I don't think we've overdone
it and I think that I think it's a
healthy expression of people saying
let's get some priorities here and let's
remember the sin and mistake that these
this nation made and let's not celebrate
it oh they're making a statement that
slavery is wrong Wow bold statement
incredible state an important statement
slavery is wrong I mean this is really a
statement that needs to be made because
because of course that the popular view
is that slavery is good you hear it all
the time right it's like every day you
walk out your house there's someone
coming up to you and defending slavery
it's the mainstream view slavery is good
and so we really need brave rebels to
come out and say no nope
you know what slavery is wrong yeah not
afraid to say and can I just and I want
to say this right now myself and I would
be very clear about this I also believe
that slavery is wrong and I am not
afraid to say it okay so that's good
healthy expression
Moe says notice here the infantilization
of these criminals that goes on Cuomo
sounds like a permissive parent
justifying his toddler's Tantrums it's a
healthy expression just part of growing
up you know this is what we call the
bigotry of low expectations and and this
is what this is what we're seeing from
Cuomo and all the Democrats Trump by the
way has has come out he came out today
and said that he's authorized the
federal government to arrest anyone who
vandalizes monuments or statues on
federal property it's always authorizing
that now I have to admit I'm totally in
favor of arresting people who are doing
this I've been saying that all along
arrest them these are felonies whether
it's federal property or not doesn't
matter what matter what property is okay
no matter where it is if it's not your
statue or your monument and you are
committing a felony because all of these
things are worth way more than five
hundred bucks so I agree with that yes
absolutely arrest the authorization part
I don't quite understand he says we're
authorizing it well this was already a
crime and law enforcement did I don't
think they need specific authorization
from the President to arrest someone for
committing a crime and I think that's
how it works I'm a little bit confused
by that number four but yes let's arrest
them please a Bloomberg reporter Stephen
Denis reports he says a day ahead of
Trump's visit to Arizona GOP senator
martha mcsalley proposes giving tax
payers four thousand dollars each to
take a vacation couples would get eight
thousand dollars in vacation tax credits
plus $500 per kid
the bill would pay for your food
beverages lodging transportation and
live entertainment events including
sporting events so alright that would be
from my
I think 10,000 bucks I've never spent
$10,000 on a vacation in my life I don't
think I've spent that much collectively
in my whole life on vacations but you
know what can I just say this is not
enough what if I want to fly first class
with my whole family and stay in a
ritz-carlton hotel and order room
service four times a day
this proposal wouldn't allow us to do
that it just wouldn't be enough money
which is outrageous this is a violation
of my rights as an American and as a
human being it basically erases my
existence it deprives me of what is
rightfully mine and I won't stand for it
finally here's a video of a giant dead
squid check it out
- I beat them
yeah
[Music]
they have nothing to say about that I
just thought it was interesting that's
it if you were if you wanted to see a
video of a dead squid today which I'm
sure you did you woke up this morning
first thing you thought is I wonder if
there's any videos of dead squids
I hope Matt plays one there you go I am
here to serve we're gonna move on to our
daily cancelation but I wanna tell you
you're not already a daily why remember
you should consider getting a reader's
pass to daily wire calm it's a great
value only three bucks a month and when
you sign up you get the first month for
only 99 cents and you also get access to
our mobile app articles ad free and
access to exclusive editorials like you
know I put stories out several times a
week
my latest wine which you can see here is
about this issue we've been talking
about about the assaults that are
happening and running rampant and so if
you want to read that get that
information get or get a reader's pass
go to daily wire comm sign up for just a
buck
it's that easy in that cheap there's no
reason not to do it okay today I'm gonna
cancel Karen not the people but the mean
it's it's a mean that I have I'm sure
you'll be quick to point out indulged
myself a time or two but I I'm tired of
it and we know that with my
cancellations it is arbitrary according
to my whim and so once once i tire of
something it's cancelled now I might
cancel it cuz I'm tired of it but then
the next day I decide I'm decide I'm not
tired of it anymore and then I'll
uncounseled it I have that authority I
can do that I'm the counselor here
Chancellor in chief but I'm tired of the
Karen thing I'll tell you why first of
all what brings this to mind is a video
that went viral today which I'm not
gonna play for you but it's it's a black
man who's filming confronting a white
woman who he says flipped him off and
called him a racial slur and in the
individual and so she does this happen
while they were driving he follows her
back to her house in the video she's
crying and terrified because he's
putting her face on camera following her
stalking her he's at her house outside
of her house and he
documents her license plate number and
her home address and shows everybody
what her house looks like what's that
all on film - puts it online accuses her
of racism most of people were sharing
the video or laughing about it saying
she's a Karin deserves to be publicly
humiliated and doxed because that's what
all Karen's deserve right meanwhile this
guy the guy who filmed it is openly
racist against white people he's an
activist his Twitter handle is literally
white people hate that's that's that's
how he advertises himself as someone who
hates white people so he's a racist
against white people advertise it is an
activists BLM activist has a history of
claiming that white people call him
racial slurs and trying to do this get
him on video
cloud chasing as the kids would call it
these days so I don't believe his
version of events at all but even he's
telling truth which he almost certainly
isn't daxing a random person in this
environment is not justified you could
get somebody killed
and this dude obviously doesn't care if
he does but this brings to mind the
whole Karen meme which increasingly has
become an excuse to intimidate and
harass random white women it is from
what I've seen recently it's taken of a
very aggressive turn and it's become now
it's not just laughing about you know a
middle-aged white woman who's calling
the manager want to speak to your
manager it's not just that now it's
let's DOX them let's harass them let's
get them on tape let's let's you know
accuse them of racism trying to ruin
their lives that's what's happening now
and here's my question because the the I
guess insinuation is that the very fact
that a woman is a middle-aged white
woman is justification in itself to
treat her this way but here's my
question would it be considered
appropriate to take a stereotypical
female name in another race and make a
negative meme out of it
you know what if somebody mocked a what
if a white person mocked a non-white
woman by calling her a name that the
mocker thinks is typical of women of
that race would that be considered funny
bit of fun a fun mean we can all laugh
about no of course not of course not it
be it would be racist it would be widely
condemned in fact someone who did that
would they would lose their job they
would lose their lively it's not just
that people would be offended it's not
just about that anymore it's never just
that now if someone took the Karen thing
which for white middle-aged white women
it's it's funny and hilarious let's all
laugh about it and if they did the same
thing for a non-white woman they they
would lose their job they would lose
their lives will be destroyed because of
it and we all know that so then why is
this okay I mean really why can you
think of any reason why the one should
be not okay but this should be okay
cerny can you come up with it can you
come up with any defense of this double
standard short of just saying it's okay
to be racist against white people that
that of course is the real answer that's
the honest answer so it's a double
standard
and for those two reasons I think it
deserves we cancelled this is a struggle
for me this kind of thing I admit
because as I said I have I have laughed
about this joke at first I thought was
kind of funny I've laughed about it
myself and used it myself but and and
and the thing is
not offended by stereotypical jokes
stereotypes don't offend me
most of the time stereo the reason why
it's a stereotype is that it's rooted in
truth I've never heard a stereotype that
is completely off base and has no truth
to it whatsoever
maybe that stereotype exists I just
haven't heard it but I personally I
can't think of one every stereotype
there's some truth to it
so the Karen thing yeah there's some
truth that not every middle-aged white
woman is like that but there is a
certain stereotype of that sort of
person who calls the manager doesn't
mind her own business so and so for that
that does exist right so that's where
the stereotype stereotype comes from it
doesn't offend me personally if people
make stereotypical jokes I don't care so
I'm fine with it and I can laugh about
it but then there's a double standard of
it too
no with this kind of joke even though it
doesn't offend me although now I'm
uncomfortable with the aggressiveness of
it so that would be enough reason you
know the self even without the double
standard to cancel it but even I'm not a
personally offended by I still don't
like the double standard
that's always the struggle when you know
with the left when it's with its
double-standards when when when people
on the left are doing and saying things
that don't actually offend you but you
know that if you said that to them they
would break down in tears that
you think well I don't want to act like
I'm offended by something I'm not and I
don't want to act like then but at the
same time I don't know what am I
supposed to just allow this double
standard to continue so that's the
balance that I haven't quite figured out
how to strike but
that you know just just allowing double
standards without calling them out is uh
is not the right approach and I think
we've I think we've tolerated it for far
too long
I think that's what we have to settle on
even if you're not personally offended
by something when it comes down to it
we're not playing this game we can't
play this game if something is racist
it's racist
period if it's racist against someone of
another race then it's racist against
white people that's that's it you
if I don't personally think it is that
if that's the rule now then that's the
rule has to be applied to everyone
all right so that's cancel and we'll
leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Sean Hampton executive producer
Jeremy boring our supervising producer
is our Mathis Glover and Robert Sterling
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico and our audio is
mixed by Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 lots of
people get accused of saying the N word
but only some people get punished for it
a prominent BLM activist calls for
vandalism of churches and they OSI steps
in a racial minefield check it out on
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]